bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
au parlement européen ici à bruxelles et
dans cette émission nous allons aller en
turquie toujours coincés aux portes de
l'europe
une procédure d'adhésion est en cours
mais cela reste un sujet de controverse
majeure surtout lorsque l'on part
l'élargissement et l'actualité de la
semaine c'est l'europe qui vient de
lever l'embargo sur les armes rebelles
syriens
nous tenterons de voir si ce qui est
présenté comme une solution ne risque
pas au contraire d'envenimer encore un
peu plus le conflit syrien
après plusieurs heures de négociations
les ministres des affaires étrangères
européens sont enfin tombés d'accord
ça y est après plusieurs semaines de
tergiversations d'annonce de démentis il
lève l'embargo sur les livraisons
d'armes aux rebelles syriens
pas trop tôt non deux ans de conflit
armé près de 100000 morts et depuis
quelques jours la preuve que bachar
el-assad utilisent des armes chimiques
contre son propre peuple
mais derrière cette déclaration c'est
une autre réalité aucune livraison ne
pourra se faire avant le 1er août le
temps à la diplomatie russe ou
américaine de faire son travail lors
d'une conférence prévue en juin
un délai qui désespère les représentants
de l' armée syrienne libre forcément
dégât collatéral cette décision a pointé
une nouvelle fois la cacophonie qui
règne dans le rang des diplomaties
européennes 27 pays
27 ministres des affaires étrangères 27
lignes et un service d'action extérieure
piloté par lady ashton
incapable d'organiser un front commun
alors les européens sont ils condamnés à
la cacophonie
alors notre invité aujourd'hui sur ce
plateau et arnaud danjean bonjour
bonjour vous êtes député européen
français vous êtes du groupe ppe c'est à
dire dont la droite ici au parlement
européen
et vous êtes également le président de
la sous-commission sécurité et défense
quelle est votre première réaction après
la levée de cet embargo sur les armes
aux rebelles syriens
je pense que c'est une mauvaise décision
je pense que c'est une décision qui est
une forme de demi mesure parce que nous
savons tous que la vraie alternative
elle est entre l'intervention militaire
qui est juridiquement militairement
techniquement impossible en tout cas
très compliqué et l'action strictement
diplomatique et politique mais qui ne
donne pas beaucoup de résultats je vous
le concède est donc entre ces deux
alternatives nous choisissons une voie
médiane
j'allais dire un peu hypocrite qui sert
à nous donner bonne conscience on lève
un embargo sur les armes qui ne sera une
levée de l'embargo qui ne sera pas
décisive qui ne changera pas de façon
décisive l' équilibre des forces sur le
terrain et qui comporte surtout beaucoup
d'effets pervers possible
déstabilisation de la région
armement de personnes que nous ne
souhaitons pas armés bref
allez faire puisque vous dites
l'intervention sur le terrain n'est pas
possible
oui et ça la rend très difficile est-ce
qu'il faut rien faire il ya 100 millions
800 mille morts ce qui lui donne une
mort mais enfin c'est pas forcément de
notre responsabilité première dont ils
ont pu se faire nous ne sommes pas
responsables de tout ce qui se passe
dans le monde et je crois pas que nous
ayons une responsabilité plus forte dans
le conflit syrien que dans d'autres
conflits
cela étant il ne faut pas rien faire
mais tout le monde dit que la solution
en syrie et les politiques nous voyons
d'ailleurs que des efforts diplomatiques
sont faits actuellement par les russes
et les américains pour avoir une
conférence que nous appelons de nos
voeux depuis longtemps donc il faut
mettre le paquet sur la solution
politique
est-ce qu'on peut s'aventurer au delà de
cette recherche de solutions politiques
je conçois j'allais dire moralement la
difficulté de l'inaction pour autant
faut-il se lancer dans des actions dont
on n'est pas certains des effets et des
dommages collatéraux qu'elle peuvent
produire moi je suis très sceptique
est ce que vous auriez dit la même chose
si ç'avait été un gouvernement de droite
en france qui avait pris cette décision
oui parce qu'il ya des personnalités de
droite éminente je pense notamment à
alain juppé qui sont plutôt favorables
cette levée de l'embargo donc c'est pas
une ligne qui a à voir avec la politique
française c'est une considération
j'allais dire de de l'enjeu syrien
lui-même de l'enjeu régional
et puis une façon par rapport à d ce
type de crise aussi d'établir une
politique vous savez les lever l'embargo
sur les armes
moi j'y suis par principe assez réticent
parce que d'abord je considère que dans
chaque conflit a beaucoup d'armes
je crois que la syrie n'échappe pas à la
règle et il ya déjà des armes par
exemple parce qu'en fait la france en
fait la france et la grande-bretagne
sont un point atteint sur ce dossier je
pense que le risque est ce qu'on en
livre déjà
non je pense pas que la france et la
grande-bretagne livre des armes en vue
d'en bas directement ce qui est ce qui
est vraisemblable comme dans tous les
conflits c'est que nous fermions les
yeux sur des livraisons d'armes qui ont
lieu dont nous avons connaissance mais
nous ne sommes pas les instigateurs
c'est un tournant un peu comme c'est un
secret je sais pas honnêtement j'ai pas
les informations j'imagine bien que
nous suivons de très près ce qui se
passe on sait qu'il ya des livraisons
d'armes aux rebelles les rebelles ne
manquent pas d'armes il manque de
certaines armes mais certaines armes
dont ils manquent
est-ce que c'est nous qui les livreront
parce que c'est la france les stocks de
l'armée française qui vont alimenter les
rebelles ce qui veut dire que nous
serons partie prenante au conflit avec
toutes les conséquences que cela peut
avoir
au niveau régional au liban sur nos
casques bleus en matière de terrorisme
est-ce qu'on laissera en fermant les
yeux sur des livraisons d'armes sensible
par d'autres pays sont des questions
éminemment compliqué et je crois que la
réponse que nous apportons au niveau de
l'union européenne est une mauvaise
réponse
mais qu'est ce qu'il aurait fallu faire
parce que là on a vu ce qui s'est passé
donc en début de semaine des discussions
marathon on vient de le voir avec cette
décision qui est une en fait une non
décision parce que de toute façon là
l'embargo allait tomber
quelle aurait été selon vous l'attitude
la bonne attitude de l'europe
je crois que la bonne attitude de
l'europe ça aurait été de passer la
journée et la soirée de lundi comme ça a
été le cas pour la levée de l'embargo
plutôt que de s'étriper sur des arguties
juridiques sur le régime de l'embargo je
pense qu'il aurait fallu passer la
journée et la soirée a essayé de se
mettre d'accord à 27 sur une ligne
politique et diplomatique à faire valoir
dans la fameuse conférence qui va
arriver entre russes et américains à
genève sur la syrie c'est une question
très importante c'est un rendez vous
très importante
je ne connais pas la ligne européenne
faut-il inviter me rend une faute il pas
invité l'iran voilà une question qui est
au moins aussi sensible que celle de
l'embargo faut-il discuter avec bachar
ou faut-il le retrait de bachar comme
préalable à la négociation
voilà des positions extrêmement
importante pour la recherche d'une
solution politique sur laquelle il n'y a
pas de ligne européenne vient consolider
j'aurais aimé qu'on se concentre sur ces
sujets qui est fautif d'andorre se
croire un peu tout le monde vous savez
c'est trop facile de jeter la pierre à
madame ashton parce qu'elle n'a pas su
dégager un consensus en épargnant les
états membres qui sont très jaloux de
leurs prérogatives en matière de
diplomatie et défense
donc tout le monde a sa part de
responsabilité il faudrait sans doute un
leadership européen plus fort mais ce
leadership européen plus fort n'est
possible que si les états membres
l'acceptent et jouent le jeu donc tout
le monde est un peu fautif j'ai
l'impression simplement qu'on se chaque
état vient avec sa propre revendications
sa propre aux priorités
sans vraiment regarder l'image l'image
globale et surtout l'image que tout cela
dégage à l'extérieur on attendait
justement l'europe unie en tout cas de
l'extérieur à un moment important et
encore une fois c'est une image quand
même de désunion qui est donné ce que la
diplomatie européenne que beaucoup
appellent de leurs voeux depuis des
décennies maintenant est ce que cette
diplomatie aujourd'hui est une utopie
n'ont pas totalement parce que quand
même des choses qui se font
je crois que il faut être réaliste on a
27 états membres
c'est la richesse et l'originalité du
projet européen de se faire aussi avec
des états des états nations et de ne pas
renier cette réalité là et en matière de
diplomatie et de défense c'est le coeur
de la souveraineté
donc c'est les domaines les plus
sensibles donc il faut pas s'étonner à
chaque fois qu'on n'est pas des
positions communes spontanée pour autant
il ya des choses qui sont l'union
européenne l'est pas totalement
inactives je pense notamment sur le plan
humanitaire et un travail absolument
colossal qui est fait avec la turquie
avec la jordanie avec le liban il ya
beaucoup de choses qui se font bien sûr
sur les décisions les plus
spectaculaires déjà lire parfois les
plus polémiques
la première chose qu'on regarde c'est ce
qu'il ya unité ou pas l'union européenne
et tout de suite on va pointer les
dissensions mais ces dissensions sont
pas totalement anormale et illégitime
c'est en europe et en gros deux deux
pays qui ont de vraies forces armées
c'est la grande bretagne à la france où
il inverse comme vous voulez est ce que
on n'aurait pas pu souhaiter puisque là
elles sont ces deux puissances ont sont
unis sont à peu près sur la même
position
est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas pu souhaiter
qui a un effet d'entraînement sur les 25
autres pays européens oui mais vous
noterez que d'autres pays font valoir
des considérations qui sont tout aussi
légitime je pense notamment à l'autriche
qui a beaucoup pesé sur ces négociations
parce que l'autriche à près de 400
militaires déployés sur le plateau du
golan dans une force de l'onu et
l'autriche craint légitimement pour ses
soldats déployés ces soldats neutre
déployés sur le plateau du golan
donc vous voyez que chacun un bon
argument aussi à faire valoir en tout
cas la plupart des pays qui sont
impliqués dans la région
un degré ou un autre ont des bons
arguments à faire valoir moi j'ai du mal
à comprendre totalement la logique de la
de la position franco britannique
si ce n'est pour voudrait dire un peu
brutalement se donner bonne conscience
montrer que nous n'avons pas rien fait
face au drame syrien
c'est respectable moralement je pense
que politiquement c'est beaucoup plus
litigieux dernière question arnaud
danjean l'un des arguments de l'autriche
et d'autres pays européens c'était de
dire
l'europe a toujours été un facteur de
paix d'ailleurs l'europe a reçu
récemment le prix nobel de la paix et en
aucun cas elle doit être un élément de
guerre en livrant des armes est ce que
ça c'est quelque chose que vous partagez
je me méfie de cet argument qui consiste
à dire on ne joue que sur le soft power
comme on dit en bon français
attention l'union européenne doit aussi
être capable de montrer ses muscles le
cas échéant en l'occurrence les muscles
français ou anglais
mais là encore ça renvoie à la question
de fond ces interventions militaires ou
pas intervention militaire
la levée de l'embargo c'est une formule
un peu bâtarde pour éviter de prendre
complètement ses responsabilités sur le
plan militaire tout en donnant
l'impression de faire quelque chose qui
se veut décisif mais qui ne sera
malheureusement pas merci beaucoup
arnaud danjean d'avoir répondu à nos
questions alors l'actualité cette
semaine en europe
eh bien ça a été l'étonnement d'un
certain nombre d'européens qui ont vu un
pays la suède s'embraser au cours de
cinq nuits d'émeutes alors dans un
instant nous allons recevoir une
consoeur une journaliste suédoise ici à
bruxelles mais tout de suite nous allons
regarder ce zapping des télévisions
européennes à propos de la sueur
regarder
d'habitude lorsqu'on évoque la suède
on pense plutôt réussite scolaire ou
bien être mais là ce sont bien les
violences urbaines qui font les gros
titres et partout les mêmes images
la scène se répète des jeunes de la
banlieue de stockholm incendient des
voitures et brisé des vitres hier soir
c'est un commissariat qu'après feu dans
un autre quartier un peu plus au sud
cinquante jeunes ont lancé des pierres
en direction de la police ailleurs dans
le pays à malmö deux voitures ont été
incendiées sur tous les écrans les
habitants témoignent d'un ras-le-bol
évident et sur bien des sujets match
nous avons une société dure ici en suède
avec beaucoup de chômage et une
éducation qui n'est pas de qualité dans
les écoles publiques
les gens ne peuvent pas avoir une vie
décente alors c'est tout un pays qui se
remettent en question le modèle suédois
n'a plus vraiment la cote
on a une espérance à explosion des ide
as they have une incroyable explosion de
violence qui a ouvert le débat sur la
politique de la jeunesse et la gestion
de l'immigration dans un pays qui se
félicite de la réputation de sa justice
sociale alors là pour ce zapping des
télévisions européennes signent et
aurélie da face avec nous sur ce plateau
teresa kuchler bonjour vous êtes
journaliste suédoise vous êtes ici à
bruxelles depuis huit ans pour un grand
quotidien suédois qui s'appelle saint
scada planète ce qui signifie le
quotidien suédois
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé parce
que nous honnêtement quand on a vu ces
images qui nous arrivait de stockholm on
a tous été un petit peu surpris
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans ce pays
dans votre pays
selon dans ce cas passé il ya deux
semaines à peu près il ya eu un incident
il ya une confrontation entre des
policiers et un homme de 69 ans dans la
banlieue de stockholm dans ce quartier
qui s'appelle view ce but et sept
personnes donc un homme dont le nom
n'est pas connu
il a menacé la police avec h et imagina
sur un grand couteau donc la police ils
ont tiré une balle et du mordant et donc
ce soit sur wii donc les deux prothèses
qui a eu des prothèses sûr que le fait
que la police n'avait pas tiré sur eux
chez nous comme les yeux de bruno devaux
et donc is a déclenché beaucoup de
rumeurs sur la comporte le comportement
de la police dans ce quartier en général
il ya eu des débatteurs disons que le
policier la police dans ce quartier et
vise les gens il demande la carte
identité pour rien donc ça commençait un
débat sur la police est ce que c'est un
quartier où il ya beaucoup de personnes
d'origine immigrée
oui c'est ça le problème en fait non
est-ce que ce que ça peut jouer dans le
dire et dans la la la violence des dans
le sens où peut-être que les gens de ce
quartier se sentent déjà un peu mise à
part et que c'était une sorte de de
colère qu'ils exprimaient là c'est
plutôt que l'ethnicité en soi bien sûr
oui c'est un quartier où par exemple
statistiques des réussites scolaires est
très laid les réussites sont basses il
ya beaucoup de chômage surtout les
jeunes ya presque 40 % des jeunes qui
nient qu'ils vont ni à l'université à
aux écoles on y travaille
donc oui ça peut jouer est ce que ça dit
quelque chose ces incidents qui se sont
d'ailleurs terminé maintenant est ce que
ça dit quelque chose sur le modèle
d'intégration
on parle beaucoup de la suède comme
étant un modèle de réussite période sur
le plan scolaire aussi est-ce que ça ça
du coup ça remet en cause des choses
chez vous voyez voilà ça c'est le débat
qui a commencé depuis ces événements je
pense que comme comme on l'a vu
après les émeutes à londres et à paris
il ya une tendance bien sûr de regarder
de ceux qui regardent loin par exemple
les français ou les anglais mais ils
font une analyse sociologique la
ségrégation l' isolement alors que ceux
qui sont dans les événements les suédois
ils ont tendance à dire non c'est de la
violence inutile ça rien à voir ça c'est
des voyous ça c'est des gens des
certaines
mal faiseur et donc mais oui bien sûr le
débat maintenant et sur la ségrégation
l'intégration et les problèmes qui peut
avoir dix qui a tué européenne et en
plus en poste ici à bruxelles vous
pensez que ce qui s'est passé en suède
trouve un écho j'ai envie de dire dans
ce qui se passe dans d'autres pays
est ce que c'est il ya je dirais ça peut
se reproduire ailleurs
oui je crois je crois que le chômage et
est un problème mondial repeint européen
je pense que le fait que ces jeunes
n'ont pas beaucoup à faire avec leur
journée on parle de l'échec des écoles
ça c'est peut-être le grand débat qui
veut que l'on va mener un grand débat de
l'échec des écoles je pense maintenant
après deux semaines quand ils les médias
ce recul un peu feront alors c'est les
écoles font débat maintenant
merci beaucoup teresa que je l'air
d'avoir accepté notre invitation on va
rester évidemment dans le domaine
européen vous savez que l'an prochain
pendant quelques semaines maintenant
l'union européenne ne sera plus 27 mai
mais 28 puisque la croatie va entrer
dans l'europe et nous nous avons voulu
savoir ce qui se passait en turquie ce
pays qui est aux portes de l'europe
depuis presque les années 60 est-ce
qu'il ya toujours un sentiment européen
et pro-européen là bas regardez c'est un
reportage qui est signée fabrice qu'une
et à istanbul et ensuite nous retrouvons
germain andrieu et son invité regarder
istanbul la plus européenne des villes
de turquie
un carrefour de cultures un pied sur le
vieux continent et la tête en asie ici
l'idée d'une adhésion à l'europe prend
parfois tout son sens
l'entreprise de mouradia ça en est une
parfaite illustration
sa spécialité les arômes pour
l'industrie alimentaire écossais
allemands autrichiens
on a beaucoup dans cette usine
donc si vous voulez on est rentré on a
fait notre propre à l'union européenne
si la turquie ne fait pas partie de
l'union des accords existent déjà en
matière douanière ou comme ici en
matière sanitaire dont ces flacons des
centaines d'arômes tous aux normes
européennes alors l'adhésion à l'europe
nour à thiès à y croire il faut décider
si l'europe c'est une europe
eurocentrique chrétien ou c'est une
europe qui est prête à partager ses
voyages avec la candidate turquie qui
attendent
l'adhésion à l'europe vous y voyez si la
dôle lui on était deux mois juillet j
quoi
l'honnêteté de l'europe l'adhésion à
l'union en turquie peu de gens y croient
encore et particulièrement la jeune
génération
dans un récent sondage 62% des 16-30 ans
n'ont plus confiance pour berra mais ses
amis
la question fait débat il ya du pour et
du contre
on ne peut pas vraiment le dire avant
mais je pense que nous devons intégrer
leurs offres et ensuite on verra bien
non non moi je ne veux pas je suis
contre l'entrée dans l'europe
je suis né en allemagne donc je sais ce
que ça signifie de vivre dans un pays
européen
il ya la crise économique le chômage a
augmenté avec l'euro et on a perdu du
pouvoir d'achat
je pense que la turquie n'a pas besoin
de l'europe
au contraire c'est la zone euro qui a
besoin de nous je pense que si on arrête
les négociations aujourd'hui c'est
l'europe qui viendra frapper à notre
porte
le processus a vraiment été trop long
les premières discussions ont débuté
dans les années 60 une longue procédure
que certaines universités explique dans
des cours de droit et d'histoire
européen
le professeur safesync gürsel est
directeur de l'un de ces départements le
problème de la turquie c'est pas qu'ils
soient musulmans mais ce qu'ils soient
trop grand nombre dans le passion disent
aussi trop grand trop peau maintenant on
dit - trop vite sans donner la situation
en europe et vu le progrès la croissance
en turquie etc
mais il est trop grand ils resteront
blanc et on n'y peut rien
en clair la turquie dans l'union ce
serait plus de députés que la france et
presqu'autant que l'allemagne alors trop
grand ou trop musulman
une chose est sûre lassé d'attendre le
pays se tournent de plus en plus vers
les pays du golfe à m excuser a ses
entrées à bruxelles pour ce chef
d'entreprise
si l'avenir de son pays et à l'est il
n'y voit pas un frein à une adhésion
c'est important pour la turquie de
s'imposer comme le pays phare de la
région et d'un autre côté il faut tout
aussi intéressant pour l'europe avec
d'intégrer dans l'union la tuerie au et
son influence locale
si les médias turcs eux sont
eurosceptiques un journal fait de la
résistance et défend l'idée d'une
adhésion
donc ça c'est une idée de l'interview
pour numéro 100 mais pour la rédactrice
en chef
l'europe fait le jeu du pouvoir
conservateur en place en turquie en
freinant les négociations un jeu
dangereux
depuis plusieurs années il n'y a qu'un
seul chapitre iv et les autres les plus
importants ce qui permet une intégration
effectifs sont bloqués donc ça c'est en
fin de compte c'est quelque chose à
double tranchant d'une part ça donne un
très bon prétexte pour le pouvoir en
place en 10 ans on voyait c'est pas nous
c'est eux parce que si nous bloque et
d'autre part quelque part ça les arrange
aussi parce qu'en fin de compte d'objets
leur objectif n'est pas véritablement de
faire des avancées rapides
pour les partisans d'une turquie
européenne l'adhésion donnerait des
garanties pour l'avenir démocratique du
pays
un droit de regard pas forcément du goût
du pouvoir en place
dernier signe d'agacement le premier
ministre erdogan a récemment fixé un
ultimatum à l'europe
la question devrait être tranchée d'ici
à 2023
voilà pour ce reportage à istanbul signé
fabrice qu name et in kazakh nous a
rejoint sur ce plateau bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes député européen vous
êtes bulgare mais également d'origine
turque
alors on l'a vu dans ce reportage avec
la turquie et l'europe ça fonctionne
déjà il ya des accords en matière
douanière les échanges commerciaux
fonctionne est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas
rester dans ce statu quo oui c'est tout
à fait vrai l'histoire comme commune
entre l'europe et la turquie se dote
depuis des années c'est vrai qu'on
avançait sur le domaine du commerce des
échanges et on a on a eu pas mal de
progrès on a eu pas mal de succès mais
bon ça ne suffit pas parce que la
turquie elle est candidate à l'adhésion
de l'europe depuis des décennies déjà
et surtout la dernière année on a
l'impression que ce processus est à
l'arrêt et c'est cette se crée des
frustrations
du côté turc est d'écouter européen
aussi parce que il y a quand même des
avantages de l'adhésion de la turquie
qui sont nettes et on a vu justement
dans ce reportage les jeunes commencent
à douter un lessive c'est 62 % des 16-30
ans et bien commencent à se lasser de
cette adhésion ce processus qui
s'éternise vous vous le comprenez c'est
s'inquiétant que la jeunesse turquie
bien commence à douter
oui parce que comme j'ai dit ce
processus est à la traîne et ans de plus
quand on entend depuis quelques années
des messages de la part des hommes et
les femmes politiques européennes qui
sont contre l'adhésion de la turquie que
son
sont en fait en faveur d'une fin d'une
manière alternatif d'approfondissement
des relations autre que l'adhésion
pleine et entière
bien sûr ça crée des frustrations et
sacré à une méfiance au sein de la
société turque surtout des jeunes alors
on dit souvent attention la turquie
pourrait se tourner plus vers les pays
du golfe
néanmoins les exportations de la turquie
pour près de moitié ont pour destination
l'europe donc finalement est ce que les
pays du golfe ça peut suffire la turquie
la turquie
est-ce qu'elle a autant besoin de
l'europe que l'europe a besoin de la
turquie
oui en fait la turquie comme vous le
savez elles se trouvent entre l'europe
et l'asie et là des territoires sur les
deux continents
elle joue le pont entre l'europe et
l'asie
donc c'est normal qu'elles qu'elles
essayent d'avoir des relations aussi
bien avec l'europe qu'avec les pays du
golfe depuis l'omnium du moyen-orient
mais bien sûr la vocation européenne de
la turquie
c'est clair et net donc la turquie elle
a toujours exprimé sa volonté de devenir
un membre un jour de l'union européenne
je crois que 7,7
cette volonté et prouver par des actes
récents des actes concrets du pouvoir en
carats dans le domaine des réformes
constitutionnelles administratifs qui
sont conquis sont donc qui vont dans le
sens de l'accomplissement des critères
de copenhague
effectivement le processus d'adhésion
est engagée depuis longtemps revanche
elle est candidate officielle depuis
on est en 2013 aujourd'hui est ce que
vous pensez que la turquie pourrait
abandonner ce processus d'adhésion
exclusivement pour se tourner vers les
pays du golfe
est-ce que ça c'est probable moi je
crois pas je crois que donc
la turquie elle n'a pas aussi une
alternative je crois que d'ailleurs tous
les intérêts pas seulement commerciaux
mais bon il ya une grande
partie de la population turque ihh a qui
vit aussi en europe déjà il ya beaucoup
d turquie vivent en europe il ya des
relations culturelles économiques
politiques qui sont fortes
donc je crois que la turquie elle va
poursuivre sa démarche de continuer les
réformes et de pousser les dirigeants de
länder européenne à faire accepter dans
les consciences madame dans l'opinion
publique européenne et la turquie elle
doit elle peut elle doit devenir membre
de l'union alors ça c'est pour du côté
turc mais du côté européen comment vous
expliquez que sondage après sondage est
bien une majorité des pays européens
et bien soit contre l'entrée de la
turquie dans l'union européenne
comment vous expliquez un petit peu ce
frein est ce qu'il ya des raisons
peut-être culturel est ce que vous
reconnaissez peut-être on a parlé de
racines chrétiennes à l'europe est ce
que ça peut être un frein par rapport à
l'identité aux turcs
oui en période de crise économique et
sociale
il est vrai que un petit peu dans tous
les pays de l'europe donc les idées un
petit peu
nationaliste les idées de fermeture les
idée de comment diriger de trouver un
bouc émissaire de tous et de tous ses
maux bien tentante de montrer quelqu'un
qui est différent du point de vue
culturel religieuses comme une menace
éventuelle de l'identité d'une cetera de
l'europe mais je crois que dès que cette
crise sera donc fini je crois que l'idée
de l'europe qui est même qui est dans
son logo c'est l'unité dans la diversité
elle trouve en elle même que bon on peut
pas faire des discriminations pour la
vision d'une telle ou telle pays par
rapport à la religion dominante dans ce
pays lorient demande effet ce que les
valeurs communes de l'europe sont
vraiment respecté par la turquie la
liberté d'expression la liberté de la
presse notamment s qui a encore besoin
de faire plus d'efforts de la part de la
turquie
oui certainement ca c
on le souligne à chaque fois qu'on ici
au parlement européen nous aident au
tour notre rapport pré guljé sur l'état
d'avancement de la turquie bien sûr que
la question de la liberté de la presse
l'ebita de la liberté d'expression est
encore y accorder d'aidé pas à faire en
turquie en cours des choses à faire mais
bon ça c'est un processus qui est bon
moi je crois que le gouvernement en
place
il fait des efforts je crois que ils
tous les autres partis doivent soutenir
ses démarches il faut qu'il y ait un
consensus au sein de la société turque
on doit avancer sur ce sur ce point
parce que la turquie ne pourra pas avoir
un donc avoir une place qu'elle le
mérite
s'il n'avance pas sur le domaine de
droit de l'autre mais selon vous vous
pensez que tous les sujets peuvent être
mis sur la table comme la reconnaissance
du génocide arménien on se souvient de
tension entre paris et ankara
il ya quelques mois est ce que ce genre
de sujets peuvent peut également être
mis sur la table
oui ça c'était ce sont toujours des
questions controversées
bon je crois que la turquie et l'union
doivent se concentrer surtout sur le
processus d'adhésion lui-même
c'est-à-dire sur le plan donc qui est de
route qui est adoptée sur l'ouverture
des champions après la trêve chapitres
sont ouverts un seul est clos j'ai
encore beaucoup de travail pour conclure
le point l'avantagent de la turquie pour
cette adhésion européenne quel est son
point fort quel est son point faible
selon vous en en deux mots oui le point
fort c'est donc la situation
géostratégique de la turquie son pouvoir
économique et donc ces compensations
source d'inspiration pour les autres
pays de la région surtout du
moyen-orient et son point faible son
point faible qu'on vous l'avez mentionné
c'est toujours c'est la question
les droits de l'homme la liberté
d'expression le pluralisme
là il y a encore des feux donc la
réforme judiciaire et constitutionnel
ce sont vraiment des mesures concrètes
que le gouvernement reste un chauffeur
et bien merci un meeting kazakh d'avoir
été avec nous et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo ici à
bruxelles avec kathia gilder et françois
beaudonnet en attendant bones une des
programmes et à très bientôt sur les
chaînes parlementaires